hey guys it is the 28th of January today
my name is Jess Mattel and you're
watching rooms but news today EA had a
revolutionary idea that games are gonna
start heading in the direction of free
to start where you start playing them
for free and then you can opt in to pay
money later of course most of us knew
these as demos 20 years ago but here's
what EA had to say Electronic Arts CEO
Andrew Wilson was talking free to play
on an earnings call when he was asked
how this model would work for consoles
this is where his theory of demos I'm
sorry free to start games comes in he
explains when we look at film television
music books very often there is this
free trial notion that actually on
boards new players listeners and readers
or new viewers into a service we're
actively looking at how we could offer
that type of experience to our players
on console and across other platforms
Wilson suggested that this would then
culminate in EA offering the player a
full game download microtransaction or
subscription or all three it's worth
noting that EA already offer early full
game trails through EA access
PlayStation Network and steam have also
regularly hosted full game trials in
past ten years of other things EA are
reviving their promising that will hear
about star wars battlefront again soon
chief financial officer Blake Jorgensen
has said the game will watch before
Christmas 2015 since it's due to a line
with Star Wars Episode 7 which will land
on December 18 the game won't be based
on the upcoming film although they're
going to share the same universe and
some of the same characters as you'd
expect yogen scence said they expect
battlefront to be on par with
battlefield in terms of levels of
activity and potential he also said
we'll be hearing more about the game in
the coming months CD Projekt RED has
announced resolution and frame rate
details for the witcher 3 and here
what you can expect the open world RPG
is going to run at 1080p and 30 frames
per second on playstation 4 and 900p at
30 frames per second on xbox one game
Star reported on the news originally and
the publisher have confirmed these
numbers are correct last year CEO Martin
of in ski said they were fairly close to
maxing out the power of both current-gen
consoles as always for PC you can run
the game at any damn ribs you like as
long as you have a beefy machine to back
it up let me know down in the comments
where you think of the witches
resolution details and what platform
you're going to play it on if you're
after more news you can head to gamespot
well we've got bits and pieces on Apple
shipping 1 billion iOS devices and the
PS Vita losing some apps that is it for
me today be sure to check back with me
same time tomorrow for a bunch more news
and have yourselves a lovely day